[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis là j'ai les mêmes territoires
tiff les mecs de tomber comme ça sur le
bout des seins ça lui fait beaucoup
c'est à dire jusqu'à la première fois
l'histoire se ferme à décrire les
parties travaillent jusqu'ici tout va
bien
justice belge maquillage et leur arrivée
veut dire entre ska qui n'en veut chérie
ça te va bien alors on sait qu'ils
marchent très bien les téléfilms surfer
sur pied ah oui noël
4 je crois pas j'espère j'espère qu'on
va souffrir pour rien moi j'aimerais me
balader d'un village de verloren clan
des vérités des chansons et boules de
noël avec comme de la neige père noël je
les collectionne
j'en ai tant à point on va presque 100
libre et des décors de noël de plein de
trucs dedans mais grégory sur ces
contrats
paquin a envoyé pour l'accession animaux
j'ai pas le temps pas grandi en
heureusement parents des taux a grandi
non d'accord on a construit les
grossières et de liquidation désolé ça
ne dérange pas ça comme un des lots
séparés des repreneurs
[Musique]
stabilisé nous aurait permis un jour ce
qui fait parler d'eux parce que moi je
te plains pas pour ça que tu as lanning
comme ça franchement non parce que je
n'ai tout que j'aime mélanger la crème
les sauces et où il n'y a qu'une section
squash n 3 c'est celle que j'aime quand
épargnée si je peux me permettre aux
battues toi tu peux facilement tout ce
qu'ils trouvent toutefois pas
ici celle formée
[Musique]